[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire suit la parution du livre de
camille kouchner la familia grande et
aux éditions du seuil et à la démission
de toutes ses fonctions d'olivier
duhamel visé dans libre l'inceste le
plus vieux tabou de l'histoire de
l'humanité est revenu au centre de
l'actualité et à chaque fois c'est
pareil c'est l'étonnement comme si
c'était nouveau comme si on n'avait
jamais pensé que ça puisse exister 10%
de la population française aurait été
victime d'inceste c'est ce que révèle un
sondage du mois de novembre et depuis la
sphère des milliers de personnes se sont
manifestées sur le hashtag me to as est
là cest a beau être l'un des tabous les
plus réprouvé ce serait aussi l'un des
crimes les moins dénoncés
alors la france at elle un problème
particulier avec l'inceste pour en
débattre nous avons invité isabelle
aubry vous avez fondé en 2000
l'association internationale des
victimes de l'inceste qui est devenu
depuis face à l'as test vous avez publié
en 2008 la première fois j'avais 6 ans
vous y raconter votre histoire ce livre
est aujourd'hui en poche chez pocket
vous en avez écrit bien d'autres depuis
et c'est un sondage réalisé en novembre
par ipsos pour votre association qui a
révélé qu'un français sur dix auraient
été victimes d'inceste les deux tiers
étant des femmes
est-ce que d'après vous la france a un
problème particulier avec l'inceste la
france ne s'occupe pas de l'inceste seul
c'est un tabou effectivement comme vous
le disiez qu'un tabou 7 ce qui est
interdit de le faire mais aussi ce qui
est interdit de dire aujourd'hui
l'inceste dans notre pays les panneaux
mais il est englobée dans les violences
sexuelles
nous nous sommes battus pendant 17 ans
pour qu'il soit inséré dans le code
pénal est défini il a été symboliquement
mais pour autant
il n'y a pas de crime spécifique
d'inceste dans notre code pénal
donc contrairement à d'autres pays
florence rault vous êtes avocate à la
cour de paris spécialisée dans la
protection de l'enfance et le traitement
de la délinquance sexuelle
vous êtes l'auteur de la dictature de
l'émotion un livre paru chez belfond
coécrit avec le psychiatre paul
bensussan est-ce qu'il ya la france a un
problème particulier avec l'unss est à
vos yeux
je ne sais pas si la france elle même un
problème avec l'un cesse ce que je
constate quotidiennement puisque je
plaide cfr quand même tout le temps
c'est que la justice
en revanche prend en compte la cest et
prend en compte ces dossiers alors on
peut on peut soutenir que l'inceste et
c'est la réalité du reste il n'y a pas
de d'infraction spécifique de crime
d'inceste dans le code pénal mais il y a
quand même dans les violences sexuelles
puisque cela fait partie des violences
sexuelles des circonstances qu'il faut
que ce crime est aggravée et au final
est réprimée et très sévèrement réprimée
du reste ce qui là aussi est assez
légitime donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y
a un problème de avec le traitement de
l'inceste
en revanche il est possible probable que
les victimes d'inceste ne se libère pas
si facilement que cela pour de multiples
raisons d'ailleurs qu'on ne va pas
développer là tout de suite mais qui
expliquerait que peut-être toutes les
situations ne soient pas mises à jour
anne-claude ambrose rendu vous êtes
historienne professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
spécialisé dans l'histoire de la justice
et du crime mais aussi des médias et de
l'environnement vous être l'auteur d'une
histoire de la pédophilie du xixème au
xxième siècle chez fayard alors est ce
que la france a une histoire
particulière avec l'inceste et bien je
vous répondrais comme mes prédécesseurs
que je ne suis pas sûr qu'à français une
histoire particulière je ne suis pas sûr
que cette histoire soit très différente
de celle des autres pays de la zone
occidentale disons et puis il faudrait
distinguer encore une histoire
particulière avec inceste ou une
histoire particulière avec la révélation
de l'inceste avec le dire de l'inceste
et c'est peut-être là qui est la
particularité c'est que la france a des
relations particulières avec ces
intellectuels et que et qu'on a vu
récemment à plusieurs occasions que
cette révélation passe par le canot des
intellectuels ce titre là qu'on peut
identifier une sorte de spécificité
française
pour le reste j'ai je pense que non il
n'ya pas de spécificité hexagonale
alors commençons si vous le voulez bien
par la loi parce qu'il ya quelque chose
qui n'est pas forcément clair pour tout
le monde sait que l'inceste en 8 même en
france n'est pas un crime mais c'est ce
n'est pas pénalisée en tant que tel le
fait d'avoir des relations sexuelles
avec un proche parent ou une proche
parente tant que ça se passe entre
adultes consentants ça ne pose pas de
problème en france c'est là où je dis
qu'il n'ya pas de crime de l'inceste
ce qui pose problème c'est quand il ya
abus sexuels de mineurs c'est quand il y
as pédophilie et là à ce moment là le
facteur le fait que ce soit un s est
peut-être un facteur aggravant c'est ce
que vous disiez florence rôle mais
est-ce que j'ai bien résumé et si ça
n'est pas le cas n'hésitez pas à
compléter la loi qui définit la cest en
france oui alors il n'y a pas de texte
dans le code pénal qui disent l'inceste
en tant que tel est une infraction crime
ou délit
ça c'est vrai que ça n'existe pas en
revanche la loi prévoit que dans un
cadre plus général des abus sexuels je
parle je prends ce terme générique parce
que on peut ne parlait que de viol on ne
peut on peut ne parler que des
agressions sexuelles mais globalement
toutes ces infractions les regroupe dans
les violences sexuelles et à l'intérieur
de ces violences sexuelles il y à des
circonstances qui font que c'est encore
plus grave que l'infraction de viol que
le crime de vie
hall où le délit d'abus sexuel et le
fait d'avoir en effet des relations
sexuelles avec un mineur qui sera de
votre famille c'est à dire qu'il faut
que vous soyez parent ou que vous ayez
l'autorité on ne parle pas forcément de
parents biologiques parce que un beau
père peut être considéré comme quelqu'un
qui aura commis l'inceste un compagnon
quelqu'un qui vit habituellement avec la
mer par exemple
donc il faut quand même considérer que
si le thème d'inceste ne fait ne
correspond pas à un article 6 du code
pénal en revanche ces situations
incestueuse sont prévues sont réprimés
et évidemment les magistrats en tiennent
compte
et en tiennent compte en fonction des
circonstances de chaque histoire parce
que chaque histoire est différente et
chaque histoire doit pouvoir être
examinés dans son intégralité
par conséquent vous avez raison quand
vous dites que l'inceste et tout le
monde a raison quand on dit que
l'inceste n'est pas prévu dans le code
mais est il nécessaire que ce soit prévu
pour que ce soit réprimé la réponse est
non puisque on le constate journellement
devant les cour d'assises et les
tribunaux correctionnels
isabelle aubry vous vous le regrettez 1
que l'inceste ne soit pas mentionnée et
ne soit pas en soi un crime en lui-même
c'est ça que vous vu entre autres que
voudriez changé dans la loi française
puisque ça fait vingt ans environ de
votre association veut changer la loi
oui alors nous avons obtenu que les
qualifications déjà existence à savoir
le le viol l'agression sexuelle et
l'atteinte sexuelle soit qualifié
d'incertain sur qualifiés d'incestueux
ce qui a aussi permis de définir qui
sont les personnes qui peuvent commettre
qui sont les auteurs susceptibles de
commettre ces agressions donc le père la
mère grand père
les oncles grand frère soeur les
conjoints de ces personnes les seuls que
nous n'avons pas pu a que dans cette
famille ce sont les cousins et des
cousines un oh ça c'est encore un combat
parce que les cousins et les cousines
représente 6 à 7 % des auteurs d'un dans
la ligne que nous aurions voulu c'est
comme par exemple au canada ou dans dont
je vous ai interrompue dans la liste que
vous venez de faire isabelle aubry vous
n'avez pas mis les les fils et les
filles est ce que ça veut dire qu'un
fils ne peut pas se rendre coupable
d'inceste
je parle une fois qu'il est majeur bien
entendu quoi que ça pourrait
éventuellement enfin est ce que ça veut
dire que les enfants ne peuvent pas
d'après vous être coupable d'inceste is
an sont forcément les victimes
vous voulez dire lorsqu'ils sont mineurs
minor qui m'atteint pas un frère une
soeur
oui ou d'un ou d'un fissure d'un ou
d'une fille non revenu fixe sur une
faille chez parler je n'imagine pas mais
j'ai sûrement tort je pensais plus
particulièrement et fils sur sa mère là
on va parler plutôt du problème du
consentement
s'ils sont tous les deux majeurs ouais
on viendra sur les en france
en france jusqu'à preuve du contraire
l'inceste entre majeurs consentants est
autorisée oui ça où il n'est pas
interdit et vous pouvez même avoir des
enfants avec un membre de votre famille
ce que vous n'avez pas le droit c'est de
le reconnaître les deux parents ne
peuvent pas le reconnaître
et ça aussi voudriez le changer
d'ailleurs on n'en est pas là un nous on
en est à la protection des enfants
c'est ce qui nous importe le plus alko
dans brothers deux rendus ça a toujours
été comme ça en france
ç'a toujours été depuis 1810 donc depuis
l'existence du code pénal l'inceste
n'est effectivement pas sanctionnés
comme tel mais il est sanctionné dans la
mesure où il est une circonstance
aggravante même si le terme n'est pas
utilisé d'un viol ou d'un attentat à la
pudeur avec ou sans violence d'ailleurs
sur sur mineurs donc il y là il a été
sanctionné est considéré comme un crime
même encore une fois si le terme n'était
pas utilisé
je comprends la revendication de qui
concerne l'utilisation du terme mais
dire que l'un c'est ce n'est pas
considéré comme un crime
c'est partiellement faux c'est à dire
que l'inceste commis par un parent même
une personne ayant autorité ou un
ascendant sur un mineur étaient bien
considéré comme un crime mais il y as
qu'il faut la question c'est de refaire
ou pas un crime à part et la question
que je me pose d'ailleurs et vous avez
peut-être la réponse c est ce que dans
les pays voisins
est-ce que l'inceste en tant que tel est
un crime
à part
l'allemagne par exemple je sais pas si
vous êtes au courant de ça françoise
role to one claude amboise rendus ou
isabelle aubry françoise florence alors
moi c'est florence
alors je effectivement dans les pays
voisins il peut y avoir d'autres
dispositions et l'inceste peut être
inscrite dans la loi mais il faut qu' il
faut que tout ça est un sens alors je si
je peux comprendre ce que veut dire
madame aubry si je trouve parfaitement
légitime
effectivement de protéger coûte que
coûte les enfants et mon dieu je sais
que j'y participe aussi bien souvent il
ya quelque chose qui m'échappe
c'est à dire que on a gagné
l'inceste est un crime à part entière on
sait que c'est un cesse et réprimer et
lourdement réprimée
alors quelle sera la différence entre
c'est écrit dans le code pénal ne s'est
pas écrit dans le code pénal
dès lors que de toute façon c'est prévu
dans le code pénal d'une autre manière
peut-être moins formelle mais qu'est ce
que ça change puisque c'est réprimées il
me semble que l'intérêt quand même de
notre code pénal c'est d'avoir déjà
prévu et d'avoir déjà évolué pour que
les choses changent bouge et
s'élargissent et qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui devant les juridictions
répressives affaires à faire réprimer à
faire punir le crime de viol incestueux
ou le verrou où le délit d'abus sexuel
sur des sur des mineurs donc là il ya
une dimension qui quelque part mes chats
je dis encore une fois sauf la
satisfaction de dire ça y est on a on a
un ou une lune un texte de loi qui
réprime un mot l'inceste
isabelle aubry ben c'est pas si simple
que ça après on va peut-être entrer dans
des dents des débats techniques mais
aujourd'hui effectivement l'inceste et
réprimer pour les personnes ayant
autorité
donc après cette autorité doit être
déterminée à ce une autorité de droit ou
une autorité de fait donc par exemple
est-ce que ça va être le cas par exemple
pour le frère ou la soeur est ce que ça
va être le cas pour la tente
voyez c'est les choses ne sont pas
toujours claires et sont soumises à
l'appréciation du juge à chaque affaire
par vous parliez d'autres pays au canada
ils ont décidé de répit réprimer
spécifiquement l'inceste ils se sont
tout simplement à ils ont ils ont décidé
voilà l'inceste c'est ça c'est commis
par telle personne et surtout on ne
questionne pas le consentement de
l'enfant
voilà une grande différence que l'on
attend dans l'évolution de la loi
est ce qu'aujourd'hui un enfant est dans
l'obligation de prouver qu'il n'y avait
pas violence menace contrainte surprise
s'il y a eu des actes de pénétration ou
des agressions sexuelles
6 il ne peut pas le prouver ce sera jugé
en atteinte sexuelle c'est à dire que
les faits l'auteur sera condamné pour
des faits pour le pour lequel l'enfant a
consenti alors fort ou trop vous êtes
d'accord avec cette vision de la bise à
l'abri non pas tout à fait parce que là
je pense qu'on confond deux notions il
ya le fait de voir inscrire dans la loi
le terme inceste et donc d'en faire une
infraction à part entière et la
présomption la présomption que l'on peut
faire de l'impossibilité pour un mineur
de consentir c'est très différent
alors d'abord je voudrais dire que
devant les juridictions quelle qu'elle
soit c'est plutôt la sphère sein qui se
passe et la charge de la preuve est
plutôt inversée là aussi c'est pas
marqué dans le code mais c'est pourtant
ce qui se passe c'est à dire que c'est
celui qui est accusé d'avoir commis de
tels actes à qui il revient
démontrer qu'une les a pas commis voyez
c'est plutôt le ya plutôt une espèce de
présomption de sincérité dans les propos
du mineur qui dépose donc là je crois
que il faut pas non plus confondre le
débat théorique et le débat pratique
c'est pas technique tant que ça un
madame aubry c'est qu'il faut voir
devant les juridictions comment ça se
passe tous les jours et il faut voir la
réaction des juges vous disiez que il
faut pas laisser à l'appréciation des
juges par exemple la notion de
consentement mais sachez quand même que
dans n'importe quelle affaire qui est
traduite en justice les juges sont là
pour apprécier les faits pour apprécier
les personnalités pour aussi se faire
leur idée de chaque affaire au cas par
cas parce que ce n'est pas si linéaire
et si simple que cela il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas d'effet qui sont forcément tous
les mêmes tout le temps donc il ya
toujours des histoires il ya toujours
des interactions et je n'imagine même
pas qu'on a eu et je pense que les juges
ont cette opinion aussi quoi qu'on
puisse juger de façon complètement
rigide une affaire sans étudier le cas
par cas et en tout cas de l'expérience
professionnelle que j'ai je peux vous
dire que étant encore passer en cour
d'assises la semaine dernière victime de
viol que l'on qualifie d'incestueux bien
sûr puisque c'était dans le cadre de sa
famille je peux vous dire que non
seulement elle n'a pas eu à démontrer
quoi que ce soit parce que parce que ça
a plutôt été à la partie adverse de
démontrer qu'il n'y en avait qu'il n'y
avait pas eu ces agissements et tout a
été épluché et je vais vous dire que le
résultat a aussi été à la hauteur de ce
qu'avaient pu subir cette jeune fille
alors france qu il faut néanmoins que
qu'on éclaircisse ça tombe de choses
parce qu'en france la plupart des gens
s'imaginent qu'il ya une majorité
minorité sexuelle qu'elle se situe à 15
ans et qu'en dessous de l'âge de 15 ans
on n'aurait pas de consentement
or si je suis bien renseigné c'est
complètement faux là il ya une
spécificité française
en france il n'y a pas de majorité
sexuelle
elle n'est pas à 15 ans comme certains
le croient elle n'est nulle part en fait
donc la question du consentement se pose
dans chaque affaire là où ce serait s'il
y avait une belle aux rites et sexuelle
à kazan les les
les fondations les condamnations padoue
serait quasiment automatique
on a des rapports sexuels avec quelqu'un
qui a 14 ans et demi il n'a pas de
consentement donc il ya viol y compris
si on avait 15 ans et demi d'ailleurs et
or c'est pour ça qu'en france on ne veut
pas de majorité ou une minorité sexuelle
là encore est ce que j'ai bien résumé ou
est-ce que j'ai tort
oui et puis en même temps je crois que
il est il est très difficile de
considérer que un enfant alors on dit un
enfant on peut dire aussi un
préadolescent quand on parle de en tout
cas d'un mineur qui aurait 13 ans aux 14
ans matures ou pas mature je crois qu'on
ne peut pas imaginer que ils puissent
dans la plupart des cas consentir à un
acte sexuel avec un majeur beaucoup plus
âgée que lui et qui évolue dans la
sphère familiale ça brouille trop les
pistes c'est encore pire évidemment
quand ça intervient chez dédé est
mineure beaucoup plus jeunes parce que
ce bilan beaucoup plus jeune va se
construire sur cette espèce de
cataclysmes et ça va être très compliqué
ensuite pour ceux pour s'en sortir ce
qui explique souvent la difficulté à en
parler parce que à des âges comme 5 ans
6 ans 7 ans l'enfant ne conceptualise
absolument pas ces notions sexuelle la
sexualité n'existe pas pour lui il n'a
pas la capacité psychique pour pour
envisager ces notions c'est que plus
tard qu on les acquiert il faut pas
confondre parfois il peut y avoir des
enfants qui ont l'air 2 mais non ils
sont pas ils sont pas en mesure de
savoir ce qu'ils font est en mesure de
donner leur consentement et à chaque
fois que j'ai accompagné des mineurs qui
étaient victimes de viols et qui avait
subi ces faits dans dans les âges de 10
13 14 ans en réalité on s'aperçoit
qu'ils ne sont pas capables de consentir
malgré les apparences et à l'adulte de
savoir poser les limites qu'il soit dans
la sphère familiale non pas dans la
sphère familiale adultes et l'adulte
l'adulte à la capacité lui de
raisonnement en principe mais après on
peut aussi voir parmi certains à
l'occasion de certaines affaires que ça
ne tourne pas toujours très rond non
plus dans la tête des adultes mais c'est
qu'il est clair que cette question du
consentement pour moi est plus
importante que le fait de savoir si on
doit mettre le mot à 16 dans le code
pénal parce que je les dis là c'est
série primée même s'il n'est pas écrit
tel quel en revanche le consentement
peut parfois quand on évoque cette
notion de consentement ça peut heurter
parfois franchement il ya des et des
circonstances dans lesquelles je ne
comprends même pas qu'on se pose la
question
effectivement mais la justice française
se pose cette question sur claude
ambrose rendu est ce que c'est une
spécificité française cette absence de
2,2 de limites claires at en dessous de
tel âge il n'y a pas de consentement au
dessus de tes l'âge il ya une majorité
sexuelle
on a l'impression qu'il n'y a qu'en
france que ce que c'est comme ça mais
c'est surtout une spécificité récente
qui est qui date de ce que nous les
historiens nous appelons le nouveau code
pénal qui n'est pas tellement nouveau
puisqu'il a il a été mis en oeuvre en
1994 mais dans le l'ancien code pénal il
n'existait une limite d'âge qui a varié
en fonction du temps qu'ils étaient 11
en 1832 qui est passé à 13 en 1863 puis
à 15 ans en 1945 limite d'âge en dessous
duquel le mineur était réputé ne pas
pouvoir consentir
il n'avait pas le dit il était considéré
comme n'ayant pas le discernement et ça
c'était dans la loi c'était dans le code
ça n'empêchait pas que à chaque procès
quelqu'un le procureur le juge
enfin il y avait toujours quelqu'un pour
discuter cette question du consentement
avec cette idée que peut-être cet enfant
à a pu être consentante voir séductrice
voire provocatrice etc
il n'empêche que dans le code la chose
était claire et ce qui est étrange c'est
que finalement le nouveau code pénal et
opérer une espèce de deux
rétrogradations cet égard isabelle aubry
donc je crois en effet je crois en effet
que le et donc voilà ça permettait de
sanctionner l'inceste de je crois qu'en
effet il n'ya pas de lien organique
entre la question de saint leu leu la
question de l'introduction du mot
inceste dans le code pénal
et cette question du consentement et le
mérite de cette loi d'avant 1994 c'est
que quand même elle évitait justement
elle aurait pu éviter si elles avaient
été prises à la lettre tous ces débats
infinis autour du consentement des
enfants ou des prêts de l'essence d'une
manière générale et de tel ou tel d'une
manière particulière je crois que ça
c'est important d'en sortir
isabelle aubry voudriez qu'on revienne
en arrière qu'on remette un nouveau une
limite d'âge clair
15 ans 13 ans oui oui 15 ans pour les
auteurs extérieurs à la famille 18 ans
pour l'inceste parce que l'enfant est
soumis et soumis et à sa famille jusqu'à
sa job majorité donc il n'a pas d'autre
choix que de vivre avec elle mais je
voudrais rebondir sur effectivement ce
qui se passe dans la réalité ce qui
m'est arrivé à meaux c'était en 81 mon
avocate gisèle halimi m'a bien expliqué
les choses et le juge d'instruction
obligé de qualifier les schémas poser la
question du consentement
même si mon père avait reconnu les faits
s'il y avait des preuves là n'était pas
le problème le problème était cette
histoire de consentement et si on allait
en cour d'assises et que les jurés
avaient un doute et considéré parce que
je n'avais pas dit non qui dit non à son
père que j'étais consentante cet homme
pouvait ressortir libre
il m'avait violée prostituée et voilà
alors donc nous sommes allés en cour
correctionnelle et il a été jugé pour
atteintes sexuelles c'est à dire des
faits pour lesquels j'étais d'accord
donc comment voulez vous après vous
reconstruire dans une société qui
envisage ce genre de choses et qui qui
vous pose cette question c'est d'une
violence inouïe pour un enfant donc
c'est ça qu'il faut changer c'est de
dire symboliquement attelage en touche
pas aux enfants quand il s'agit de
lancer ses 18 ans voilà on protège voilà
ce que notre société a décidé pour
protéger nos enfants ont fait une pause
et bien je vous poserai la question à
toutes les deux est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec isabelle aubry on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
une bonne stratégie pour l'état de venir
en aide aux entreprises c'est en cas de
défaillance est ce que véritablement
l'état lève sa garantie et rembourse aux
banques
le problème de ces sociétés là il est il
est là depuis longtemps ça fait
longtemps que renault ne gagne pas
d'argent en vendant des voitures quand
le marché se retire on s'aperçoit les
entreprises qui ont constitué des
réserves financières suffisantes et les
sociétés qui n'ont aucune réserve
financière et qui ont fait des dettes
considérables depuis depuis à peu près
une centaine d'années concrètement est
ce que l'état joue gros dans un système
qui serait un système normal il jouera
gros
et aujourd'hui vous avez des banques
centrales qui qui imprime tant qu'elles
peuvent donc que vous soutenez
artificiellement un système qui est mort
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise lorsque c'est
arrivé c'est histoire personne ne
prenait ça au sérieux nos métiers il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris après
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restaurants
c'est pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je c70 mieux c'est aussi tout
un questionnement sur la société sur le
rapport à la solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre donc dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
on continue ce débat avec isabelle aubry
qui est la présidente de l'association
face à l'inceste avec florence rôle qui
est avocat et un claude ambroise le
rendu qui est historienne
alors on a vu le philosophe alain
finkielkraut justement parce qu'il
posait la question du consentement dans
la sphère olivier duhamel le
consentement de la victime se faire
sanctionner par la chaîne de télévision
et on se souvient de ce qu'on en a vu
l'extrait le présentateur de l'émission
lui disant à 14 ans il
il n'y a pas de consentement on voit
bien que tout tourne autour de cette
affaire de consentement et on a
l'impression que la justice française
accorde une place prépondérante à cette
notion alors est ce qu'il faut comme le
disait isabelle aubry juste avant la
pause que l'on mette une une limite
d'âge strictes
elle proposait 18 ans dans les cas
d'inceste et sinon 15 en dessous duquel
la question du consentement ne se pose
plus puisque il ne peut pas y en avoir
florence rôle alors d'abord il faut
quand même noter que en termes de
justice une différence est faite puisque
des agressions sexuelles
quand elles sont commises sur un mineur
de 15 ans ou de moins de 15 ans le
traitement n'est pas le même la peine
n'est pas la même non plus donc on fait
quand même cette distinction à partir de
l'âge de 15 ans en dessous de 15 ans on
considère qu' il n'y a pas de
consentement et il faut parfois posé des
questions mais ce ne sont que des
questions pour déterminer et motivé le
fait qu' il y eut surprise contrainte
menace violence il faut quand même il
faut comprendre qu'il faut quand même
qu'il faut au bout du compte que les
juges puissent motivé
jugement c'est suffit pas de dire il est
coupable ça fait tant et points
non il faut motiver endroit en motifs
une décision donc on considère qu'en
dessous de 15 ans il n'est pas question
de consentement mais qu'au dessus de 15
ans un adolescent qui a dépassé les 15
ans pourrait éventuellement consentir à
des relations sexuelles cela étant il ya
peu de magistrats qui apprécie que ça se
passe avec le père par exemple d'un
enfant c'est c'est clairement établie ça
vous pouvez pour être plus grand chose
raconte mais il ya eu des affaires en
france et encore récemment ou une fille
de moins de 15 ans qui avait eu relation
sexuelle avec un homme assez âgé
beaucoup plus âgé qu'elle plus de trente
ans si je me souviens bien à l'âme est
ressorti libre
parce que les sept jeunes filles de
moins de 15 ans a dit qu'elle était
consentante
visiblement a dû le prouver puisqu'on
n'a pas poursuivi l'homme de plus de 30
ans voilà ce ne serait pas possible s'il
y avait une majorité et une minorité
sexuelle auto bannissant il aurait été
condamné
si on parle de la même affaire cette
affaire est en appel et on n'a pas
encore là la décision finale puisqu'il
n'y a pas encore de position qui était
éprise et je crois que ça n'a pas été
jugé encore en appel c'est pas certain
que ça reste sur la même décision qu'en
première instance
mais là encore ça ne oui on peut on peut
mettre cet âge mais ça existe déjà en
dessous de 15 ans il est il n'est pas
admis que l'on puisse avoir consenti
c'est déjà comme ça que ça va suivre
donc attention les que l'agression
saison vous parlez toutes les deux en
même temps vous entends place alors
isabelle
aubry ensuite un coup dans buzz revenus
si on peut avoir une condamnation pour
atteintes sexuelles sans violence menace
contrainte ou surprise ce qui veut dire
quand on raconte la victime était
d'accord était consentante
adam braz rendu en europe où les ânesses
en on aura une condamnation mais mais on
considérera que la victime était
consentante même si elle a 10 ans c'est
ce que je voulais dire c'est pour ça que
je parlais c'est pour ça que je parlais
de rétrogradation parce que dans
l'ancien code pénal l'attentât à la
pudeur sans violence et prévoyez bien
qu'il ne pouvait être pas y avoir de
consentement dans ce cas là non plus et
l'attentât à la pudeur sans violence
était un crime ou d'un délit
françois fall oui mais pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas posé effectivement le
défaut de consentement la possibilité de
consentir mais vous savez c'est moi je
moi je crois et par expérience je le
constate que les magistrats font bien
cette distinction et qu' ils n'admettent
quand même que très très rarement qu'il
puisse y avoir un consentement alors ad
âge de 10 ans 11 ans la sphère dont vous
parliez monsieur taddeï
moi je n'en connais pas d'autre qui soit
qui alors je ne connaissais je ne
connais pas les tenants et aboutissants
exacte du dossier mais en tout état de
cause c'était la première fois que
j'entendais parler d'une affaire dans
laquelle on considérer qu'un enfant de
11 ans avait pu consentir à des
relations sexuelles avec quelqu'un d'une
trentaine d'années je me souviens qu'à
la suite de cette affaire justement il y
en a de nouveau parlé de d'introduire
une majorité minorité sexuelle en france
le débat est allé à l'assemblée
nationale la grande surprise de là
encore des français qui croyait que ça
existait alors qu'ils sont rendu compte
que ça n'était pas le cas et je me
souviens que l'assemblée nationale je
crois me souvenir de que emmanuel macron
il serait bien de mettre ça à 15 ans et
que l'assemblée nationale a refusé
l'assemblée dachary a refusé le sénat a
refusé également justement parce qu'il
disait il faut que ce soit jugé
individuellement à chaque fois pour
chaque cas de façon différente et
paquets pas une automaticité qui
voudraient dans son côté le plus absurde
que dans le cas de deux mineures de
moins de 15 ans les parents de chacun
porte plainte contre l'autre comme s'ils
avaient violé leurs enfants et ou
simplement que un mineur de 15 ans et
demi soit condamné pour avoir eu des
rapports sexuels avec une mineure de 14
ans et demi par exemple donc pour toutes
ces raisons là ça a été écartée en
france anne-claude en bronze rendu
vouliez non oui ça c'est assez facile de
répondre à ça il suffit de prévoir une
différence d'âge de 5 ans je ne sais pas
enfin voilà de poser une limite qui
constitue un barème et ça évite
justement des condamnations d'un d'un
mineur de 15 ans et demi
mais c'est pas ça n'avait pas l'air
aussi simple je me souviens du débat et
c'est pour ça que ça n'a débouché sur
rien est ce qu'on s'est dit hier des
histoires d'amour merveilleuse en train
entre quelqu'un qui a 18 ans et demi qui
aura 14 ans et demi et qu'on va pas le
réprimer systématiquement fin bref y est
plein de bonnes raisons visiblement en
france mais on va pas rester sur ce
débat à l'infini
je voulais vous poser une autre question
est ce que ray chez nous une tolérance
c'est quelque chose qu'on a beaucoup
pour tendues depuis quelques jours il y
aurait une tolérance en général
d'ailleurs on a crime et 68 ce serait
forcément mai 68
alors en matière de de pédocriminalité
et et en particulier en ce qui concerne
l'inceste
anne-claude amboise rendu est ce qu'il
ya une tolérance et est-ce que mai 68
aurait joué un rôle
bon c'est une très vaste question vous
me posez là à laquelle il est difficile
de répondre de façon nuancée
je ne sache pas qu'il y ait une
tolérance particulière en france ce qui
existe ce qui existe et ça n'est pas
qu'en france essaie depuis des siècles
voire des millénaires c'est une espèce
de règlement et de surdité à l'égard de
la réalité de l'ensemble des agressions
sexuelles commis sur les mineurs
bon et cet aveuglement cette surdité on
est en train d'en sortir péniblement
avec des à-coups etc et ses traits et
c'est très heureux que mai 68 et avoir
quelque chose ait quelque chose à voir
là dedans ça me semble être un mauvais
procès qu'on fait à 7 à cette période
bon alors c'est un procès qui est assez
à la mode depuis un certain temps on
incrimine mai 68 pour beaucoup de choses
tout ce qui concerne le relâchement
supposée des moeurs le grand n'importe
quoi qui aurait été introduit par mai 68
dans la société française et je crois
que ce faisant on confond le baromètre
et la réalité c'est à dire que mai 68 en
posant la question de
des normes en posant la question de la
libération sexuelle a permis que soit
mise à jour la réalité des pratiques
sexuelles entre adultes et mineurs et
donc la réalité de la criminalité
sexuelle perpétrée par des mines des
majeures sur des sur des mineurs mai 68
est pas responsable de cette réalité là
que mai 68 est fournie à un certain
nombre d'agresseurs un argumentaire
élaboré intellectualiser justifiant le
ces rapports sexuels ça oui mais les
agresseurs n'avaient pas besoin de mai
68 pour développer un argumentaire on en
trouve d'autres tout au long du xixème
siècle et jusque jusque dans les années
70 qui prennent d'autres formes mais qui
permettent aux agresseurs de se
justifier à leurs propres yeux et
d'essayer de se justifier devant la
justice je crois me souvenir que je
crois que c'est en lisant votre livre
mais vous allez me corriger si ça n'est
pas le cas on mettait ça je parle de la
cèze cela c'était un truc qui étaient
liés aux campagnes
c'était campagnard tu est les paysans
qui que l'on soupçonnait de se rendre
coupable de genre de choses
oui bien sûr c'était le c'était le crime
de l'arriération quasi mentalement tout
cas intellectuelle
c'était le crime des pauvres et le grime
deux de ses campagnes notamment des
campagnes de l'ouest considéré comme
très violent très archaïque quasi
barbare et les médecins d'ailleurs avait
un peu participé à cette représentation
qu'ont totalement totalement mythique
et puis à la fin du 19e siècle qu'on
commence de considérer que non
finalement là c'est ce doit être aussi
assez répandu en milieu ouvrier
ce qu'on découvre l'inceste urbain et
finalement c'est assez tardivement dans
le xxème siècle qu'on s'est rendu compte
que l'inceste existait dans tous les
milieux dans les milieux bourgeois aussi
simplement on avait mis un peu plus un
peu plus de temps à le découvrir parce
que la bourgeoisie protège mieux ses
secrets de famille
françoise florence pourquoi françois
florence rault pardonnez-moi tolérance
pas tolérance à votre avis non je non
non je crois pas je suis je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est à dire que y'a pas de
milieux particuliers il n'y a pas que
chez les ouvriers que ça et partout aux
quatre coins de la france et pas que y a
pas que dans l'ouest des dossiers comme
ça moi j'en pèse absolument partout
effectivement ça ça peut s'expliquer par
certains comportements certains modes de
vie certaines moeurs mais que l'on peut
retrouver dans tout l'est vraiment dans
tous les milieux il n'y a pas de il n'y
a pas un endroit qui serait privilégiée
exempt épargnés c'est si répandue
et je ne pense pas en tout cas toujours
de mon point de vue de l'avocat bien sûr
les deux et deux mois qui pratiquent ces
questions là tous les jours c'est
quelque chose qui est pris au sérieux
qui et quand c'est dénoncer traiter et
qui est jugée et de façon de façon
absolument pas bienveillant qui loin de
là c'est sans concession d'accord
isabelle aubry il n'y a pas de tolérance
à écouter c'est compliqué parce que on a
une justice qui n'a pas de moyens donc
déjà les victimes en ont du mal à aller
porter plainte
parfois il leur faut beaucoup de temps
elles le font pas toujours pour elle
même le fonds pour protéger d'autres
enfants de la famille et souvent et bien
on se retrouve face à des classements
sans suite dé correctionnalisation ce
qui nous ce qui fait que finalement nous
aboutissons à un crime qui est quasi
impuni puisque on considère que
seulement 1% des agresseurs seront
condamnés et ça ce ne sont pas nos
chiffres sont les chefs du ministère et
justice et qu'il faut relativiser
il faut relativiser quand justement que
par rapport à vos chiffres puisque c'est
votre sondage paru en novembre qui
révèle que 10 % de la population
française aurait été victime d'inceste
mais surtout c'est moins repris dans la
presse c'est quand même pour deux tiers
sont des femmes qui sont victimes
donc là cest ce serait un crime masculin
comme la plupart des crimes sexuels
d'ailleurs donc c'est peut-être dans les
mythes dans tous les milieux mais c'est
pas tout le monde
n'est pas un criminel sexuel un criminel
à cestus en puissance c'est plutôt les
hommes alors les les auteurs sont
effectivement plus souvent des hommes à
92 95 % il ya aussi des femmes qui nient
qu'ils passent à l'acte si on à 78 % des
femmes se révèlent victimes et seulement
22 % d'hommes et bien c'est parce que
les hommes ont plus de difficultés à
révéler ce qu'ils ont subi est un enfant
du fait notamment des préjugés
homosexuels qui ont encore beaucoup
enfin qui existe dans notre société mais
nocifs de 10% je tiens quand même à lui
dire commencent à rejoindre les chiffres
d'amérique du nord
mais on est encore en dessous à mon avis
de la réalité ce sondage vous le fait
régulièrement depuis
depuis 2009 la première fois ce tour
si je me souviens bien à l'époque nous a
été est retombé sur le chiffre de 3% de
la population française donc ça aurait
plus que triplé mais je crois savoir
qu'à l'époque c'était un sondage
effectué par téléphone
aujourd'hui c'est un sondage effectué
par internet ça change pas mal de choses
et ça pourrait expliquer l'augmentation
que vous découvriez oui alors la
première fois effectivement nous
l'avions fait par téléphone et nous
savons très bien que ce type de violence
est difficile a révélé comme ça au
téléphone à un être humain
on est passé en 2015 parent sera sondage
online est donc là nous avons doublé le
chiffre puisqu'on est passé à 6 % et
donc là on a voulu voir en 2020 avec la
vague mythe ou s'il y avait
effectivement une libération de la
parole parce que lors de la vague mythe
où on a vu beaucoup de victimes
d'inceste s'exprimer par contre ce
qu'elle disait n'a pas été identifié
dans les médias ou sur les réseaux
sociaux comme étant de l'inceste
donc on a refait le sondage est
effectivement
eh bien on est encore arriver à un
chiffre plus important puisqu'on est à
10% de la population soit
6 7 millions de personnes avec
exactement les mêmes questions et en
2009 sur ces chiffres un commentateur
françoise euros florence rault je ne
connais pas à ces chiffres
particulièrement vous savez il y en a
maintenant un peu un peu ici et là
moelleux la seule jauge si je puis dire
que je peux avoir c'est ce que je vois
dans les cour d'assises et devant les
tribunaux correctionnels et
effectivement c'est de ces dossiers
occupe une très large part les violences
sexuelle inceste ou pas inceste occupe
une très large part des des audiences
mais je reste réservé par rapport à ces
par rapport à ces chiffres
un sondage on peut lui faire dire ce
qu'on veut aussi à notre lot d'amboise
rendu oui moi aussi j'ai tendance à être
très méfiante à l'égard des chiffres
notamment vu ce qu'ils deviennent ils
sont utilisés comme comme justement des
arguments irréfutables et tout argument
irréfutable me semble toujours un peu un
peu
dangereux en tout cas il était interrogé
mais je pense que la progression elle
même et quand même intéressante
indépendamment du chiffre de la donner
la progression nous dit quelque chose de
ce qu'il est devenu possible de dire de
révéler dans l'espace public ou à ses
proches d'ailleurs et ça c'est
intéressant il me semble que ça montre
juste que quelque chose change et c'est
plutôt une bonne chose est que quelque
chose change à la faveur de du mouvement
mis tout est révélateur aussi de la
nature de ces crimes au fond alors c'est
vrai que mythe ou 1,16 que le hashtag
nitoo inceste est née aujourd'hui même
il y avait énormément énormément de de
communication de circulation sur ce
hashtag qu'est ce qu'il révèle à vos
yeux isabelle aubry ce que l'on peut
lire sur mythos inceste
qu'est ce que vous y voyez vous je vois
que les victimes une fois encore
prennent la parole les proches aussi de
victimes pas seulement elle est que pour
une pour la première fois s'est
identifié comme étant de l'inceste et
que c'est repris par les médias comme
étant de l'inceste mais les victimes
parlent depuis longtemps en fait moi
j'ai créé l'association il ya vingt ans
sur internet je vais la conviction qu
internet serait l'outil de libération de
la parole salah a été scellée de plus en
plus avec les réseaux sociaux notamment
moi j'ai quand j'ai publié mon livre en
2008 c'était encore un témoignage rare
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de livres
nous avons 2500 témoignage sur notre
site
nous avons beaucoup de personnes qui
osent en leur nom prendre la parole sur
les réseaux sociaux
voilà et ça ça c'est si c'est assez
récent fait c'est être de quelques
années il ya pardon il ya une question
que j'ai oublié de vous poser tout à
l'heure c'est sur la scream elle l'a
prescrit bilité de dori de ces crimes
ils sont prescrits je crois que parmi
les choses que voudriez changé dans la
loi en france et que vous voudriez les
rendre à prescriptibles c'est bien ça
oui nous nous sommes d'ailleurs fondé
sur cet objet parce que au canada comme
dans tous les pays de common law les
crimes graves sont imprescriptibles et
nous nous considérons que pouvoir
poursuivre un auteur c'est pouvoir
protéger les enfants tout simplement
alors bon après on nous oppose toujours
les mêmes arguments depuis vingt ans
mais on a quand même avancé de deux fois
dix ans c'est déjà pas mal mais ce n'est
ce n'est pas suffisant parce que parce
que comme on le voit le
inceste et un crime transgénérationnel
et comme je le disais tout à l'heure
souvent les victimes veulent prendre la
parole porter plainte aussi pour
protéger les générations futures et il
ne faut pas qu'elle soit bloquée par la
prescription
françoise rhône en france je crois que
yahia que les crimes contre l'humanité
qui sont à se crêper script cible oui et
je m'appelle toujours pas françoise
toutes mes excuses
cette question de la prescription de ce
genre d'infraction je comprends que ceux
qui ont été victimes puissent il a
réclamé et en même temps il faut bien
considérer que aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
a été victime d'agressions sexuelles
pendant sa minorité aura jusqu'à l'âge
de 48 ans pour déposer plainte pour
libérer sa parole comme on dit et pour
faire examiner son affaire
48 ans et déjà un âge très avancé à 48
ans si on n'a pas découvert qu'on a été
ou si on n'a pas eu la possibilité
encore de de dénoncer ce que l'on croit
avoir subi je ne sais pas quel âge on
pourra à elle être en mesure de le faire
et ça va poser quand même un grave
problème parce que que faire des preuves
que faire comment faire un procès avec
tout ça on le voit bien à chaque fois
que la parole a tardé on a de plus en
plus de mal à juger des affaires en
revanche que la parole se libère c'est
très bien mais qu'elle se libère
vraiment et qu'elle se libère rapidement
parce que là on peut encore faire des
procès sinon on est réduit à à semer la
discorde dans une famille on est à son
nez dans certains milieux amené à
condamner
dia tiquement quelqu'un sans procès
équitable et sans qu'il y ait pu y avoir
quoi que ce soit de discutables je ne
suis pas certaine que pour la victime
elle-même ce soit satisfaisant
en tout cas toutes les victimes que j'ai
pu accompagner mon toujours tenu les
mêmes propos c'est à dire que peu
importe ce que dit la justice ce qui les
intéresse c'est que celui ou celle
qu'elle dénomme comme étant leurs
agresseurs et reconnu les faits c'est ça
qu'il est guéri c'est ça qui cautérise
leur plaît et c'est pas tellement c'est
pas tellement le reste en fait et le
procès leur fait presque plus de mal que
de bien
mais entendre son agresseur dire oui je
t'ai fait du mal ça j'ai pu constater
que ça faisait faire un grand pas à la
victime de ses agissements et que ça lui
permettait de tourner la page et de
passer à autre chose en tout cas de
passer à autre chose de façon plus
sereine
donc je ne suis pas certaine que c'est
un prescrit bilic a prescrit petit
bilité pardon soit nécessaire elle
n'existe pas par exemple pour des crimes
de sang or il ya plein d'affaires qui ne
sont pas résolues pour lesquels on et
marées que cette prescription ne soit
jamais atteinte pour pouvoir si jamais
la science il faut lui faire évoluer le
dossier mais en même temps il ya un
moment où il faut être capable de passer
à autre chose et de s'arrêter parce que
sinon c'est impossible
et sinon on risque d'être avec des
histoires qui ont pu évoluer qui ont pu
changer et on aura aucune certitude de
rien alors je ne sais pas si c'est ça
qui est intéressant ou si c'est plutôt
le fait de d'apprendre à nos enfants à
parler d' apprendre à nos enfants à ne
pas se laisser faire de dans l'éducation
qu'on peut leur donner leur donner les
moyens
de ne pas tolérer ça ça me semblerait
sûrement plus intéressant mais si le
point de vue que d'ambrose rendu oui
mais je vais pas revenir sur sur les
arguments qui effectivement sont les
mêmes depuis depuis longtemps il ya
effectivement la question du
dépérissement des preuves
il ya aussi la question simplement de du
principe de la justice française en tout
cas qui est une justice dans laquelle il
ya une espèce de droit à l'oubli et ça
me semble ça me semble important alors
peut-être faut-il l'art de la relire
entièrement et puis il ya évidemment la
question du crime contre l'humanité qui
me semble pas alignable pour des raisons
historiques qui sont bien
compréhensibles sur l'ensemble des
autres crimes
je crois qu'en effet il serait sans
doute plus plus plus rentable si j'ose
dire de de prévenir de prévenir
l'inceste en interrogeant davantage les
structures familiales et les structures
patriarcales dans lequel cet inceste est
possible tout simplement parce que les
enfants ne disent pas non à leur père je
vous remercie tout les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous remercie de
l'avoir suivi et je vous donne
rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]